to order
the professional agenda for this meeting
reports of the Secretary General of the
Sudan and South Sudan the agenda is
adopted
rules of procedure
I invite the representative of South
Sudan it is
so decided
thank you
foreign
[Music]
a Madam president thank you for this
opportunity to address the council today
on the situation uh in South Sudan
I acknowledge the presence of the
interim chairperson of rjmac General
Charles guitar and the president of the
community of cyanogenia Professor Marco
in pagliazo who will respectively brief
in detail on the status of the
implementation of the revitalized
agreement and engagements with the
non-signatory parties
for my part I would like to begin by
noting that the crisis in Sudan has
implications for the implementation of
the revitalized peace agreement in South
Sudan
the impact of that conflict or unfurling
along multiple fronts
since mid-april over 117
000 women and children and men have
crossed over into South Sudan from Sudan
along the border areas
93 percent of these are South Sudanese
returnees I want to commend the
government of South Sudan for its open
border policy to all those who are
fleeing the conflict with or without
travel documents
the absorption capacity of the
government and humanitarians in South
Sudan however is under strain with
limited local resources and bottlenecks
of arrivals in South Sudan's border
towns notably in rink
the economic impacts of the conflict
caused a shadow on an already fragile
country context
the sudden Interruption of imports from
Sudan has resulted in essential
Commodities being Out Of Reach for
ordinary people in South Sudan
crude oil exports from South Sudan
through Port Sudan are an economic
Lifeline which if interrupted as
recently threatened could have
devastating effects on the south
Sudanese economy
on the political side the conflict in
Sudan reduces the much needed bandwidth
both domestic and international of to
focus attention on South Sudan during
this critical phase of its transition
while President care and egad's efforts
to end the conflict in Sudan remain
commendable the timeline of the peace
process in South Sudan should not
allowed be allowed to become the
opportunity cost of these efforts
in South Sudan these factors are
exacerbating the existing triggers and
drivers of conflict complicating an
already tenuous security situation
across the country for example reports
of Northern migratory cattle herders
refusing to return to Sudan are
concerning
the absence of local agreements
governing the movement of cattle outside
the drive season heightens the risk of
clashes between Northern pastoralists
and South Sudanese agrarian communities
furthermore there is increased
competition over scarce resources in
areas of new displacements resulting in
an escalation of tensions amongst
communities often with a tribal overtone
in an environment marked by prevailing
economic hardship pre-existing communal
tensions and the presence of firearms
recently the developments in Upper Nile
State underscore just how combustible
these factors can become in a short
space of time
with a simple trigger rapidly igniting
underlying drivers in a deadly sequence
of events as has happened in rank and
Mullica over access to water points
concerningly amongst these events one of
our own poll offices was held against
his will by 30 idps for several hours
especially on the 7th of June a 14 year
old shaluk resident of the protection of
Civilian sites the POC site was stabbed
to death the newer man was subsequently
beaten to death sparking deadly clashes
between armed youth militias unmisses
verified that at least 14 idps were
killed and 28 injured including one
woman
at the request of the state's
Authority's humanitarian Partners have
temporarily suspended the movement to
molecule of new Rivals from Sudan
currently in rank but continue to
facilitate the voluntary movement of
people to their chosen destination or
other destinations across South Sudan
in the aftermath of this latest event I
visited molokol to observe the Dynamics
on the ground myself
we are reviewing our integrated response
with both uniformed and civilian
response and the effectiveness of our
coordination with South Sudan Security
Services
as matches stand approximately six to
seven thousand newer have now left the
POC site with only the shaluk community
remaining and in what is now a
monoethnic site
humanitarians are adapting their
response plans to support both
communities inside and outside the camp
and threats to the site have far from
receding only increased
on Mrs prevention plan includes the
deployment of intensified patrols and
over 600 peacekeepers on the ground
we'll be reinvigorating cordon and
search operations to search and remove
firearms from the camp which has
designated a weapons-free Zone we are
supporting Community leaders and their
responsibility to de-escalate and take
ownership of conflict resolution efforts
this is backed by engagements with
national and local political leaders who
set the overall tone for inter-communal
tolerance and peaceful disarmament
we also appreciate the support that has
been extended by the governor of open
Isle the South Sudan people's Defense
Forces South Sudan Nationals Police
Service and the National Security
Service in restoring relative calm and
preventing reinforcements by armed youth
from malakal town
Madam president
the flare-up of tensions in Mullica only
adds to the much wider Patchwork of
intercommunal and sub-national conflicts
that the mission is grappling with
on the recent publication of the unmiss
human rights quarterly briefing we
expressed our alarm at the reappearance
of extrajudicial killings in warup and
Lake States and they've engaged the
government in these serious violations
of human rights
we further urge the government to
publicly release the findings of the ad
hoc investigation committees which have
been established by the president
meanwhile the renewed unmissed mandate
requires us to undertake additional
protection of Civilian tasks these must
be commensurate with capabilities and
resources in a context where our
protection mandate is operationalized on
a mission-wide cross-cutting
responsibility using the full range of
tools at our disposal
in that regard Our intention is to
extend the forces footprint across the
country while still retaining reserves
for addressing intercommunal and
sub-national and pre-electral
contingencies
I note that we await the outcomes of the
ongoing military and police capability
study which will respond to our question
of whether we are fruitful purpose
and despite our geographical constraints
I note that a recent independent
perception survey shows there is still
support and Trust among South Sudanese
in in the stabilizing presidents offered
by unmiss
Madam president after four years of
incessant rainfall some parts of Sudan
South Sudan are bracing for a drought
the extended dry season and let rains
will impact the crops fueling further
insecurity and vulnerability criminal
activity targeting food items is on the
rise
in bore in one incident to learn seven
metric tons of food were stolen in
yongle wfp had to pause has had to pause
the pre-positioning of food for the
third time this year
attacks on humanitarian personnel and
assets are unacceptable
humanitarians must be able to safely
deliver life-saving supplies to those in
need
unmiss continues to provide wfp convoys
with Force protection and we are
collaborating on further enhancing
coordination and operations
with needs increasing and resources
dwindling humanitarian Partners have
made the difficult decision to divert
resources from ongoing responses to
address emerging critical needs
including of the newly arrived
vulnerable returnees and refugees from
Sudan
I commend the emergency relief
coordinator for allocating 8 million US
dollars
eight million US dollars from emergency
funds and request donors in the broader
International Community for their
support
the 2023 humanitarian response plan
to reach vulnerable people estimated at
6.8 million with urgent vital support is
less than 30 percent funded
on a more positive note I'm pleased to
inform of progress on the Nile River
Corridor initiative our engagement with
the governments have resulted in an
agreement to reduce the number of
checkpoints from over 30 to 6. unmiss
will continue to support the government
to actualize this
Madam president
now is not the time to take our eyes off
the ball in South Sudan what we can
learn from Sudan is how quickly hard-won
peace gains can unravel
this underscores the need for full And
Timely implementation of the revitalized
peace agreement
we are informed
by the recent egad communicate that the
political impulse over the removal of
the minister of defense and Veteran
Affairs has apparently been resolved but
not acknowledged as such
we urge the parties to avoid taking
unilateral decisions we also request
redoubling of efforts and support of
constitution making and election
preparations
in our estimation the
constitution-making process is 10 months
behind schedule elections planning is
nine months behind and several aspects
of the transitional security
Arrangements remain hanging
as it stands today at South South Sudan
is not ready to roll out an electoral
process
we've heard this directly from
government members political parties and
Civil Society
who all recognize that there's a new
urgency to deal with these imperatives
however we also believe that with the
United effort amongst all parties and
the appropriate political will it may be
possible for South Sudan to make up the
gap
to that effect I welcome the initiative
of the government to form a Joint Task
Force with the UN egad and the Au to
advance the constitution-making and
electoral processes which
held its first meeting a few weeks ago
I further urge the relevant stakeholders
to double down on passing the national
elections act in Parliament and to stand
up the national elections commission so
that the South Sudanese people can begin
to decide the form and content of their
new constitutional intellectual system
however no electoral process can be
credible and successful without adequate
Civic and political space for all
citizens to participate in it and a
great deal needs to be done in this
regard
I welcome the engagement of civil
society and quarterly dialogues with
unmiss's leadership on the requirements
to expand Civic and political space and
to address the nature of their
participation in it
as well as our engagement with the
leadership of political parties in the
political party's forum both groups
underscored the need for urgency if the
elections are to be held next year
Madam president in conclusion the
challenges are many
but I'm hopeful that with cooperation
partnership and sustained leadership a
positive change in the lives of South
Sudanese can be achieved oh thank you
Madam president
they all said permit me to congratulate
you and the United Arab Emirates from
being elected member of the United
Nations group Council for the year
2022-2023
and assuming your second presidency for
the council in the month of June 2023
I would like to thank you for inviting
The reconstitution Joint monitoring and
evaluation commission RJ Meg to address
this student's Council
RJ Mech is the official oversight body
responsible for overseeing monitoring
and evaluating the status of the
implementation of the 2018 Revitalize
agreement on the resolution of the
conflict in the Republic of South Sudan
arakris and are mandated to submit
reports and brief this Council amongst
others on quarterly basis
over the last five years of the
implementation of the agreement
South Sudan has enjoyed its longest
period of relative peace and stability
since its dependence in 2011.
however the pace of implementation of
the agreement has been slow and as much
of what was expected to have been
implemented by the end of the stipulated
period of 36 months of the transition
period was not achieved
consequently the reverter is peace
agreement was extended for 24 months
from February 2023 to February 2025 to
enable the completion of the unification
forces the making of the permanent
Constitution and prepare for the conduct
of credible free and fair elections in
December 2024
my previous August Council therefore we
will briefly highlight our assessment of
the South Sudan peace process and the RJ
makes ongoing efforts in support of its
implementation and conclude with some
recommendations
Madam president
overall key achievement in the
implementation of the agreement include
the following under governance the
executive and legislative arms of the
refactorized transition government to
National Unity are techno has been
established and operationalized at both
the national and state levels the
dispute over the number of states was
resolved and the revitalized peace
agreement was incorporated in the
transition Constitution
also some crucial legal judicial and
institutional reforms are ongoing
on the transition security Arrangements
approximately 55 000 of the 83 000 phase
one necessary unified forces who are
trained and graduated
these troops remain in their training
areas awaiting deployment to their
respective units
however phase two
and disarmament immobilization and
reintegration DDR process is yet to
commence
own humanitarian Affairs the opening of
key humanitarian corridors has
facilitated the return of some South
underneath refugees and idps
some economic reforms have been
implemented and encouraging greater
transparency and accountability but this
too remains work in progress
on transition Justice progress is being
made in the drafting of the bills for
the establishment of the commission for
truth reconciliation and healing ctrh
and the compensation and reparations
Authority cra
once these institutions are established
they will drive forward the March needed
process for reconciliation and healing
in South Sudan
in terms of a permanent Constitution the
law to govern its making has been
enacted and steps are being taken to
operationalize it I would like to
underscore that the agreement states
that elections at the end of the transit
period should be held under the
permanent Constitution
Madam president
the main challenges which have slowed
down progress in the implementation the
Revitalize peace agreement include trust
deficits among the parties lack of
adequate resources capacity gaps
persistent levels of winter communal
violence in the states negative
activities of the holdout groups and the
natural calamities like Florence
most recently additional strain has been
placed on the humanitarian and other
resources in South Sudan by the influx
of refugees and writtenes from the
conflict in the Republic of Sudan
Madam president
elections are due in December 2024 which
is around 18 months from now
in order to conduct free fair and
credible elections the following
critical benchmarks need to be attained
as Patriot's peace agreement a
completion of the invocation and the
deployment of forces in order to provide
election rate and security B
reconstitution and operationalization of
the institution's tasks with the
preparations and conduct of Elections
namely the political parties Council and
the national election commission C
the making of a people-led people-owned
permanent Constitution to guide the
conduct of Elections d
judicial reforms to enhance the capacity
and Independence of the judicial
institutions to deal with election
related disputes and a Improvement the
overall political and Civic space in
which multi-party elections are
conducted
at this critical conjunction of the
extended period of the revertise
agreement the other thing requires more
support from this Council and the
International Community for it to be
able to complete the implementation of
the critical Penny tasks of the
agreement
without predictable and adequate funding
our assessment is that South Sudan will
continue to struggle to endear the
implementation schedule of the arakris
in rjmx view the International Community
can support the South Sudanese efforts
especially by directly funding the
Constitution making process the
settlement immobilization and
reintegration DDR as well as the
preparation and conduct of Elections
Madam president
with regard to rjmx efforts in support
of the implementation of the revitalized
peace agreement
rjma continues to Monitor and evaluate
and oversee the Mandate and tasks of the
art techno including the adherence by
the parties the agreed timelines and
implementation schedule in a conduct
chapter 7 of the advertise peace
agreement
RJ makes objective and impartial reports
and all-inclusive stakeholders monthly
plenary meetings continue to inspire
confidence in the peace process and
encourages the parties to stay the
course of peace
you know regular quarter evaluation
reports to the error technique to egad
to Au peace and Security Council and to
this council help create Focus Unity of
purpose and informs policy decisions
making on South Sudan and the
implementation of the agreement
continues to oversee the work of
agreement institutions and mechanisms
breaks Deadlocks among the parties and
regularly engages the parties to the
agreement key peace partners and others
of Sudanese stakeholders in a bay to
build consensus and exploit progress
in conclusion Madam president
I would like to underscore that arakris
legitimize is the translation of
government of national Unity South Sudan
and Remains the most plausible blueprint
for a peaceful transition and in
building a dwelling peace in the
Republic of South Sudan
with a prospect of Elections looming on
18 months away there is Need for our
Collective efforts to focus on South
Sudan at this critical time and ensure
that the agreement is prevented in
letter and spirit
in that regard I would like to appeal
this Council to remain Seas of the peace
process in South Sudan engage the Arctic
new to expedite implementation of peace
agreement and to conduct elections are
scheduled and to consider facing jupa at
this critical time of election
preparations understanding solidarity
with the people of South Sudan I thank
you
Madam president honorable members
for more than 50 years the community of
San Diego has been a peculiar
International actor
a community close to the vulnerable
people dedicated to peace interreligious
dialogue
humanitarian Aid and also able to
conduct International mediations and
facilitation in different parts of the
world
from the peace agreement in Mozambique
signed in Rome in 1992 to Burundi from
Guatemala to Kosovo and Mindanao indeed
we believe that war is the mother of all
poverty today I am addressing you about
the crisis in South Sudan
I want first of all to thank the United
Arab Emirates presidency for inviting us
to testify about our work before this
Council
Santa judia has been following with care
and concern the situation in South Sudan
since the 90s well before its
independence
several times Dr John garang the
Founding Father of the country visited
our air quarters in Rome to seek avenues
for dialogue in the midst of a struggle
for Independence
our initiative called the Rome
initiative was born in the aftermath of
the signing of the revitalized agreement
in the complicated phase of creating the
government of national Unity
several political and Military entities
had reject that agreement and it was
necessary to retrieve them
Pope Francis personally intervened since
the memorable spiritual retreat in
Vatican those was created the
precondition for conveying the
non-signatories to derividualize the
agreement in Rome with a full mandate
from president salvakir to negotiate
with them
the Rome initiative led to Mutual
recognition between the government and
non-signatory opposition and created a
negotiating framework for political
engagement
despite forced interruptions due to the
covid-19 pandemic this dialogue has
reduced the level of violence in the
country and created New Hope For Peace
Madam president Jerome initiative
allowed representatives of the Soma the
alliance of non-signia tourists to be
trained for their future inclusion in
the
CTS amvm the process is more inclusive
now and it is moving further in that
direction the ROM initiative represents
a political dialogue complementary tool
and in harmony with International
institutions Santa gido is committed to
continue on this path with the intention
of creating favorable ground for
eradicating violence
at this level I must mention the
important contribution made by Civil
Society representatives and leaders of
the countries Christians and different
religious denominations
this participation will only increase in
the coming stages and is a decisive
impetus in calling government and
opposition leaders to their
responsibility towards the South
Sudanese people and their suffering
finally
I would like to thank those who have
supported and are supporting this effort
with active participation and constant
exchange of import of information and
guidance the United Nations mission in
South Sudan through its representative
Nicholas Hazen the countries of the
region egad for its efforts in obtaining
the revitalized agreement as well as the
institutions board for its
implementation and in particular the RJ
Mac the CTS am
and final Detroit United States United
Kingdom and Norway the Swiss
Confederation Canada Italy Japan an
international organizations such as wfp
and icrc thank you for your attention
I'll begin by giving the floor to the
United States uh thank you madam
president uh thank you special
representative haysom Ambassador guitar
and Dr impogliazzo uh for your
comprehensive briefings today
the United States is alarmed by the June
8 reports of deadly intercommunal
violence in the malakal protection of
Civilian site
we condemn the reported attacks and
offer our deep condolences to the
families affected by the violence
we commend the governor of upper Nile
State and State authorities working in
coordination with unmiss on
strengthening security measures
including securing the perimeter of the
malachau POC site
while we also commend unmissed for its
rapid deployment of peacekeepers to
quell the violence we are concerned that
the mission had not adopted measures to
address potential violence in advance
despite early signals of tensions
between the two communities
we look forward to the results of the
independent assessment by October 15 on
unmissed implementation of its
protection of its civilians mandate and
where we need to help the mission
address gaps
we are gravely concerned for the welfare
of civilians and internally displaced
residents who remain in a vulnerable and
life-threatening situation in and around
the Malachi camp
we are also alarmed by reports of armed
groups moving towards the POC site as
well as rumors concerning the presence
of small arms inside the camp
we urge on Miss in close coordination
with State authorities but unilaterally
if it must
consistent with its mandate to restore
calm and security and ensure protection
of civilians and idps inside and outside
the camp especially vulnerable
populations
we further urge South Sudanese
transitional authorities to prevent such
Movement by armed groups towards the POC
site
the influx of civilians from continued
fighting in Sudan has further
deteriorated South Sudan's already
declining humanitarian situation and
cause greater strain on the POC site
over one hundred thousand individuals
have crossed the border from Sudan into
South Sudan with the expectation that
180 000 more will cross over the next
three months according to unhcr's and
iom's emergency response plan
coupled with a cost of living crisis
consecutive years of flash floods that
have damaged viable land for cultivation
and livelihoods as well as a continued
outbreak of waterborne and other
diseases in several States this crisis
has placed a further strain on social
cohesion
immediate implementation of the
transitional government's commitments is
the best way to ensure the effects of
the sedan crisis can be mitigated in
South Sudan
despite these challenges despite the
challenges this country faces
South Sudanese officials need to make
progress on implementing the roadmap and
political transition
we again stress that the only way for
the transitional government of South
Sudan to achieve a successful transition
to a permanent government is to create
and maintain a stable environment where
civilians are protected
South Sudan's transitional leaders must
deliver the results they committed to in
the peace agreement and address
immediate issues such as the ongoing
violence in Upper Nile State and the
dire humanitarian situation
the United States remains committed to
the cause of peace and to the people of
South Sudan thank you madam president
of the United States for their state
thank you president and I also thank a
special representative he's a major
general Thai getoy and Professor
impalatza for their briefings today
Malta Fuller supports efforts towards a
peaceful and stable transitional process
in South Sudan with the revitalized
agreement and its accompanying roadmap
at the center
will reiterate our call for the timely
implementation of all pending tasks and
for the transitional period to be
completed without further delay
we welcome the recent graduation of
troops for the necessary unified forces
at the same time we also underline the
need that they are sufficiently trained
and deployed to regions in the country
that face increasing outbreaks of
violence
we are concerned about the implications
from the ongoing political impulse and
we encourage parties to continue
honoring their commitments as envisaged
in their vitalized agreement
while we support the agreements
verification bodies including rjmac
we reiterate our call for constructive
engagement
it is only through an inclusive Civic
space that the Electoral and
constitutional processes can be achieved
by the end of 2024 we'll highlight the
importance of a national elections act
to be posed followed by the
reconstitution of the political party's
Council and the national elections
commission all necessary conditions for
the contact of free fair and credible
elections
furthermore multi-support schools for
the reinforcement of the 35 percent
quota for women as prescribed by the
peace agreement and urges their full
equal and meaningful participation in
all processes including the
Constitution's drafting
today we are pleased to hear voices from
civil society and other associations
such as the community of Santa gido
which can spearhead a sustained and
Lasting peace
we welcome the efforts being made by the
authorities of South Sudan and hosting
over a hundred thousand people that seek
Refuge from the conflict in Sudan
we also government the role that
president salvakir has displayed Within
egad mission towards mediating a
ceasefire in Sudan
malt is deeply concerned with the
Recruitment and radicalization of Youth
with children often being the first
victims of conflict and great violations
are still being registered who support
charge protection measures and welcome
in this context child protection
training conducted by unmiss we also
underline the rule that you'd have to
play in shaping a lost ink piece
has vulnerability to violence is present
in Upper night and younglaced States we
deployed violent scenes at malakal POC
site in the upper Nile State on 28 May
we call for calm and underlined the role
of local leaders in encouraging their
communities to refrain from violence
Malta condemns all acts of sexual and
gender-based violence we support the
deployment of U.N police officers in
high-risk areas and the work of unmiss
by conducting capacity building
activities underlining the need for
accountability and the protection and
Rehabilitation of survivors
with 76 percent of South Sudan's
population in need of humanitarian
assistance climate rocks and floodings
continue to precipitate instability
we are supportive of life-saving and
needs-based humanitarian assistance
including through key EU funded projects
amounting to it among million euro this
year alone
Malta strongly condemns all attacks
against humanitarian personnel and
convoys and reiterates that perpetrators
must be held accountable
we can recommend the use of Petro's burn
Mist to ensure the protection and safety
of humanitarian workers
precedent to conclude Malta reiterated
support to special representative case
in London Miss with the reinforced
mandate since last March to Renewal but
with the same determination that has
driven its work
as unmiss continues to assist the
government's primary responsibility to
protect civilians we urge for all
parties to seize all violence and to
solidify a transition that places the
Destinies of the people of South Sudan
at the front and center I thank you
president
the honor of making the statements
of the A3 countries namely
in my own country Mozambique
would like to yeah
which was very edifying
so thank you
Major General Charles
president
interim church
is also extended to Professor Marco
president
of the community
we thank them
for their commitment
to the cause of peace throughout the
world
we welcome the participation in this
meeting today our brothers is Excellency
permanent representative of South Sudan
Madame President
it is the firm belief of the A3
that South Sudan has been making
important progress
towards the consolidation
of the state and the rule of law
particularly regarding the
Constitutional and electoral process
the inaugural meeting of the Joint Task
Force
for advancing the Constitution making
and electoral process
held on 1st June
2023 is a clear testimony in that regard
while acknowledging the efforts being
made by the country
it is important that all parties
work collectively to overcome their
political differences and sustain the
progress
achieved so far
the A3
welcomes the engagement of the members
of the quartet
comprising only miss
the African Union Mission in South Sudan
Diego special Envoy and the
reconstituted joint monitoring and
evaluation Commission
in supporting the efforts of the South
Sudan stakeholders
particularly
in addressing the current political
Deadlock
we call on the parties
to honor their commitments and expedited
the implementation of the revised
agreement
including completing the outstanding
tasks
required before the end of the
transitional period
the A3
strongly believes
that a firm commitment of all parties
will pave the way for the consolidation
of political stability
towards lasting peace and sustainable
development that the South Sudanese
people are eager for
Madame President
the A3 notes with appreciation the
reduction in incidence of intercommunal
violence
at the sub-national level
particularly in the jungle state
nevertheless
we remain concerned
over the Persistence of vulnerability to
violence in some regions of the country
mostly communal and cultural related
this vulnerability
is further
exacerbated by climate shocks that
continue to have a negative impact on
the security situation of some
communities
causing severe disruptions of
livelihoods
protracted displacement and human
insecurity
especially with the convergence of
cattle herders in the same areas
initiatives to promote dialogue between
communities and cattle herders
focusing on the sharing of resources and
peaceful coexistence are powerful tools
that need to be further leveraged
we urge the International Community
to continue supporting such efforts
the A3
encourages unmiss to continue taking
measures to protect civilians
mitigate violence and support peace
dialogues within the scope of its
mandate
engaging local and traditional leaders
to this collate tensions and facilitate
conflict resolution
we further encourage unmiss to expand
its technical assistance
and support
to accountability mechanisms and
strengthen the criminal justice chain
aligning accountability support with the
dialogue and the reconciliation
processes across South Sudan
the A3
writeratis they are called on the need
to reinforce capacity building actions
to relevant South Sudanese authorities
particularly in logistical financial and
judicial matters for enhanced protection
of Civilian response
we take this opportunity
to reiterate
that attacks on civilians are
unacceptable
we condemn in the strongest terms these
heinous actors
The Spill of effects
of the current military confrontations
in the Sudan remain a matter of great
concern
the influx of South Sudanese nutanis
Sudanese refugees and Third Country
Nationals combined with the reduction in
the flow of goods and full well from
Sudan
places further pressure on vulnerable
communities and exacerbators the already
dire humanitarian situation
due to efforts of the government and
humanitarian workers the people in South
Sudan have been receiving
humanitarian assistance despite the
occurrence of attacks targeting
humanitarian convoys and we commend all
such efforts
the A3 therefore strong condemns attacks
on humanitarian workers and calls on all
parties to respect International
humanitarian law and give
unhindered access to humanitarian
organization
Gabon gun and Mozambique
encourage unmiss to continue its efforts
in supporting South Sudanese authorities
to create conditions to facilitate
humanitarian assistance to the people in
need
while welcoming the Afghan Union and the
Igor post-conflict needs assessment for
South Sudan the A3
reiterates our call for the
International Community to step up its
financial support for humanitarian
assistance which reminds severely
underfunded
Madam president
[Music]
Universe
continuous violence in the country girl
and in this regards
the government
[Music]
measures violations
children's rights
quantities
and the African Union
within a comprehensive holistic approach
in conclusion modern president
in Mozambique
Express their gratitude deep gratitude
the truth and police contributing
countries
for their commitment and the good
sacrifices they've made
and to open up a pathway to Lasting
peace in the country I thank you madam
president
China
Madam president representative
conditions for the political transition
[Music]
such as Constitution making and
generation
and promote National reconciliation at
the same time
the security capacity of the government
to improving the security situations
impact on the maintenance
of unjustified sanctions
should continue to increase their
financial supports out to South
constructive support for the peace and
development in South Sudan thank you
madam president
Ecuador
um
at this meeting
[Music]
this is
a serious humanitarian crisis
[Music]
to carry out foreign
um
is of training women towards this goal
in addition
my delegation that it is
[Music]
human rights Defenders
members of the media to do their work
foreign
Inter-Community violence
and by the president
we encourage the government
continue
to achieve sustainable peace
[Music]
any restrictions
thank you very much
for his update and underline our support
for unmiss I also thank General Charles
Tai Gateway and Professor Marco
impalasio for their import informative
briefings
let me also thank the community of San
Diego for the work they do in different
countries thank you
and we welcome the presence of South
Sudan to this meeting
president Albania welcomes the secretary
General's report and shared his concerns
about the challenging situation in South
Sudan which has worsened by the ongoing
fighting in Sudan leading to an influx
of weapons refuges and interruptions of
cross-border trade
I'll briefly touch upon three areas
firstly we are concerned by the delayed
process
and progress in the implementation of
the revitalized agreement and roadmap
we welcome advancements on the
Constitution making and electoral
processes but further efforts are
required to expedite the progress and
facilitate the transition to a permanent
government
we call on the transitional government
to focus on advancing outstanding
reforms including passing and enacting
the national election act and turn the
deployments plan for the nuf into
concrete actions
the government must also work with own
myths to effectively prepare for
peaceful and inclusive elections
ensuring the meaningful participation of
women and Civil Society
secondly the protection of civilians
remains a strong concern
this is this further hampered by ongoing
sub-national violence across South Sudan
regions like upper Nile and jungle have
witnessed significant violence Mass
displacement and high levels of sexual
violence
similarly we expressed
deep concerns about the recent ethnic
clashes in the malacal posc site we urge
the government to intensify its efforts
in tackling the ongoing violence prevent
further escalations and ensure
accountability
to descend the influx of refugees from
Sudan including South Sudanese return is
raises concerns about the risk of
further intercommunal violence and
ethnic clashes the government must work
to address the root causes mitigate
tensions and collaborate with Ole Miss
to scale up the protection of civilians
thirdly the dire humanitarian situation
including food insecurity requires our
attention criminality and Road ambushes
targeting humanitarian and Commercial
convoys have affected over 460
000 people we call on the government to
facilitate safe and unimpeded access for
humanitarian Partners to deliver
critical Aid across South Sudan
we strongly condemn violence against
humanitarian personnel and assets and
call for full accountability for these
crimes in conclusion Madam president the
Electoral and constitutional processes
are crucial elements to building a
stable and peaceful South Sudan we
cannot afford the spillover effects of
Sudan to impact the transition processes
the government must redouble its efforts
implement the outstanding benchmarks of
the peace agreement and work closely
with Ole Miss to lay the ground for free
fair and Democratic elections and I
thank you
evaluations
scheduled foreign
foreign
[Music]
is 5.8 million Euros
which continues to play a central role
in protecting civilians and building
companies
and contributing expertise in weapons
provided by the United Nations
thank you
president
[Music]
and it's become an additional heavy
burden for the country and it gets this
background will welcome the political
and diplomatic efforts made by the
president
he has been undertaken since the
beginning of the confrontation
and other countries in the region know
very well with the difficult political
Trends in that country and that is a
prerequisite for finding ways for a
settlement
the government has managed to advance in
the areas of State Building implementing
the commitments
military graduates at the same time
between the various opposition groups
[Music]
significantly to stabilizing the
situation and the implementation of the
peace agreement we Advocate close
coordination of efforts between unless
and local authorities so as to
successfully settle intercommunications
foreign
president
I thank the special representative of
the Secretary General and head of Amis
Mr Nicolas hasten internment chairperson
of RJ Mick Major General Charles pie
Gateway
and president of the community of Santa
gidio Professor Marco in pagriato for
their insightful briefings
Japan takes note of the recent SG report
on Amis which describes progress and
challenges in South Sudan and highlights
the relevance of the Mandate of the
admission
Japan would like to thank all Personnel
of Amis for their service in protecting
civilians and mitigating violence in the
challenging environment
as a TCC we are committed to our
continued deployments to Amis
I would like to make the following Four
Points concerning the long-term peace
security and stability of South Sudan
which are closely linked to the Mandate
of Amis
first
it remains crucial to implement the
revitalized agreement on the resolution
of the conflict in the Republic of South
Sudan
the implementation should be in line
with the timeline timelines established
in the adapted roadmap as the basis for
sustained peace in South Sudan
in light of this we commend the progress
such as the approval of the national
election act 2012 Bill 2023 and the
ongoing preparations for the deployments
of the necessary unified forces
however we are concerned that the
implementation for other aspects have
been delayed
Japan like to call for all stakeholders
to cooperate with the South Sudan to
implement the agreement comprehensively
to ensure that general elections can be
held in December 2024.
second
we have seen a reduction in incidents of
inter-communal violence at the
sub-national level however we are
concerned that the situation can be
aggravated by the influx of returnees
and refugees from Sudan
as for this we welcome president salvak
Hills engagement with regional leaders
to resolve the conflict
Japan would like to emphasize with the
necessity for more International
coordination and continued collaboration
thirdly it is necessary to arrange for
the early deployment of the necessary
unified forces with due consideration of
the Strategic Defense and Security
review
it is also necessary to unify the
Commando structure and the development
and develop weapons and Armament
management among other important tasks
lastly we welcome that the South
Sudanese government is Corporate
cooperating with the unau igat and
related organizations in various areas
however there are continuous
to be numerous violations of the status
of forces agreement as well as attacks
on humanitarian assistance operations
we are particularly concerned about
undue restrictions on taxation by the
government
it is necessary to have greater
cooperation with unmiss to ensure it can
fully Implement its mandate
in conclusion Japan stands by the
government and people of South Sudan in
their Endeavor to steadily implement the
RX and we strongly support Amis as well
as humanitarian players in this regard I
thank you madam president
I thank the representative of Japan for
their statement I give the floor now to
the representative of the UK
thank you president
and thank you srsg heyson
mate General Gateway and Professor
impagliato for your briefings
I also welcome the presence of the
representative of South Sudan in our
meeting today
president as we've heard fighting across
the border in Sudan has exacerbated the
already critical humanitarian situation
in South Sudan
around 120 000 people have been
registered crossing the border moving to
areas already faced with significant
humanitarian needs and aggravating
political and intercommunal tensions
the United Kingdom welcomes the
government of South Sudan's provision of
Transport for people returning home and
other refugees
we encourage all efforts to maintain the
Safety and Security of all returnees
refugees and host communities
we commend the UN system and
humanitarian partners for their Swift
response to the crisis and we urge an
agile strategy and careful risk
management for this evolving context
the United Kingdom is particularly
concerned by the recent intercommunal
fighting in the malachal protection of
civilians Camp resulting in the reported
killing of 13 people and burning of 4
000 homes
we welcome the response by unmissed
peacekeepers to de-escalate these
tensions
and their wider efforts to protect
civilians across South Sudan
to prevent further tragedies occurring
we need urgently to find solutions to
the tensions in melakyl and address the
root causes of South Sudan's fragility
the United Kingdom reiterates our call
on the south Sudanese government
to do all it can to stop sub-national
violence
provide basic Services first people and
deliver meaningful progress on its peace
agreements
we welcome the recent
taking task force co-chaired by SRS G
hasten
however electoral and
constitution-making processes are now
over nine months behind schedule as we
heard with the national elections act
and National constitutional review
commission still awaiting reconstitution
legislation alone will not deliver
sustained sustainable peace in South
Sudan
laws need to be enacted
and the institutions they create need to
be financed
there needs to be a peace dividend
dividend
the United Kingdom remains committed to
the people of South Sudan and their
Journey towards peace and stability
we call on the government of South Sudan
to expedite this journey by stopping the
violence and ending corruption
and by delivering Justice essential
services and free and fair elections for
its people
thank you
I thank the representatives
to the representative of Brazil
thank you madam president I begin
by thanking a special representative
hasten
General Thai guitar and professor in
Palazzo for their knowledgeable insights
I also thank unmiss RJ Mack and the
community of Center gidio for their
valuable work
I acknowledge the presence of Ambassador
and welcome the delegation of South
Sudan to this meeting
Madam president as other council members
Brazil remains concerned
about the facts in South Sudan of the
ongoing hostilities in Sudan
we regret that happy fighting north of
the Border has let thousands of people
to leave their homes split families and
flee Sudan many of them many of whom to
South Sudan
we are worried about the pressure on
scarce resources in South Sudan
particularly in the upper Nile State and
Ryan County
we are especially concerned about the
situation in parts of South Sudan they
lack food and clean water
we worry that the kind of a fighting
over resources that we saw in malakal
could spread and even raise ethnic
tensions elsewhere
in this context Brazil fully supports
the tireless work that unmiss unhcr and
Ocha have done in South Sudan since the
outbreak of conflict in Sudan
crucial for the International Community
to provide the additional funds that the
Secretary General unhcr and Ocha have
requested in recent Appeals
additional and flexible funding for food
security and humanitarian assistance in
South Sudan is pivotal
for preventing conflict
we deplore
the attacks that have killed
humanitarian agents in the line of duty
and express our condolences to their
families and loved ones
call on South Sudan to redouble its
efforts to provide safety for those
essential workers and make sure that
perpetrators are brought to Justice
Madam president
persistent violence in abier Upper Nile
John glalay and elsewhere
makes it clear that the current
peacekeeping efforts would benefit from
additional peace building initiatives
we have already expressed our
appreciation for do for the growing
involvement of South Sudan with the PBC
nevertheless South Sudan and the
International Community can do more to
support additional efforts in peace
building
the community of Center digu's briefing
today shows yet again the critical role
that dialogue and conciliation play in
the pathway to sustain peace
we believe that conflict resolution
tools inherent to peace building are
valuable to South Sudanese civilians
especially women girls and boys who live
outside and far away from Juba
widespread widespread teaching learning
and the use of these instruments would
lead to a diverse virtuous cycles that
sustain peace and prevent new waves of
violence thank you
representative of South Sudan
related responses
to establish the institutions
conflict prevention
to strengthen the rule of law
foreign
[Music]
moving forward
foreign
[Music]
organizations
South Sudan
president
as this is my first time to deliver a
statement since you assume the
presidency of the security Council allow
me to congratulate you and your
delegation for the manner in which you
have steered the functions of this
console
also allow me to welcome and thank our
briefers in the person of Professor
heisam the srg
and General Charles getoy
the interim our game Act
and
the president of San Diego
Professor Marco and bagliazzo
for their insightful briefing they have
offered to the security Council it is
our hope that it contributes positively
towards our shared goal for sustainable
peace and Security in South Sudan
I would also like to thank the
distinguished ambassador of Mozambique
and the rest of the A3 for their
comprehensive and welcome statement
Madam president
my delegation took note of the report of
the Secretary General on the situation
in South in South Sudan submitted
pursuant to Security Council resolution
2023 which requested the Secretary
General to report on the implementation
of the missions mandate every 90 days
Madam president
over the period within which this report
was documented
South Sudan has experienced relative
peace and security across the country
the revitalized government is committed
in seeing that the country is in total
peace and life of a common citizen
returns to normalcy
towards this goal
Yuba continues to extend the Olive
Branch
to those who are still outside the
revitalized agreement
we call on all the peace loving Partners
to join us in consolidating what has
been achieve and work collaboratively to
involve those who are still outside the
Revitalize agreement to reach on an
agreement that will allow the country to
enjoy a lasting peace
we acknowledge the significant delays in
meeting the agreed upon benchmarks and
remain committed to Expediting the
pending tasks necessary for the
successful implementation of revitalized
agreement
therefore
we would like to assure the
International Community
that despite the challenges we are
facing
we are committed to do all we can to
make meaningful progress towards these
goals
Madam president
in the report submitted before you the
Secretary General reminded the security
Council of the impact and Devastation of
floods flowing 40 Years of incessant
rainfall
and its implication on the work of the
peacekeepers especially in mintu where
dikes need to be further enhanced
this year
due to poor rainfall in some part of the
country
it is expected that we will experience
poor harvest
which will result in cases of starvation
and possible internal displacement and
migration
in most cases created security related
instabilities and communal tension
we recognize the threat caused by floods
drought and related climate shocks to
the stability and the security of our
nation as we have witnessed across the
country between the cattle Keepers and
farmers
we urge the International Community and
universe to join South Sudan through
initiatives that will prioritize
conflict prevention early warning and
invest in sustainable development
through agreed mechanism of mitigation
and adaptation
that does not leave no one behind
Madame President since the Inception of
conflict in the Republic of Sudan
South Sudan experience whose migration
of refugees and returnees from the Sudan
given the quick turns of events
we are caught flat-footed
and no emergency preparation were
readily available
and given South Sudan already difficult
humanitarian situation and economic
challenges we do not have the immediate
financial capacity
to be able to rescue the dire situation
while we are thankful for the efforts
done so far
we are appealing to the International
Community to double its efforts and
commitment to help the displace
Madam president
the government of South Sudan wishes to
express our deepest appreciation
to the eunamis egot and those countries
who are assisting in the implementation
of the roadmap and we urge those
partners and Friends
who are yet to join in support of the
implementation of the roadmap
to come to come in to allow
[Music]
the parties to effectively and
positively implement the roadmap and
allow for successful conduct of the
general election as provided for in the
revitalized agreement
Madame President South Sudan is grateful
for the ongoing support of your name is
African Union egot or gamac and San
egideo
and other related organization and
mechanism within the Revitalize
agreement as well as the troops and
police contributing countries that are
helping to ensure our continued progress
towards the brighter future
we assure the International Community of
our continued commitment
to the implementation of revitalized
agreement and achieving lasting peace
and stability in South Sudan
in conclusion Madam president
notwithstanding the challenges the
Revitalize agreement faces in the
implementation of the revitalized
agreement the parties are committed to
its full implementation
we strongly call on the International
Community
and Regional partners and Friends of
South Sudan not to give up on South
Sudan thank you for your kind attention
speakers
thank you
uh